ich muss ehrlicherweise sagen wir
zeichnen diese sendung hier am frühen
abend auf das heißt ich konnte die
abschließende pressekonferenz der beiden
gar nicht mehr sehen
möglicherweise sehen wir jetzt doch
schon im handelskrieg und ich werde
morgen eingezogen das ist da muss irgend
einer rheinbrücke bewachen man weiß es
am ende hatte die kanzlerin das müssen
sie mir vorstellen hatte die kanzlerin
mit dem präsidenten der usa nur 20
minuten vier augen gespräch für so
komplizierte themen trump hat ihren
besuch ernsthaft zwischen andere ihm
offenbar wichtigere termine gequetscht
davor hatte er olympia-teilnehmer
empfangen und direkt danach fing ja auch
schon die neue folge spongebob an das
muss man respektiert immerhin hatte
merkel gestern einen schönen abend in
washington in einem imbiss da ist etwas
passiert das hat sich wirklich seit
jahren nicht erlebt
[Applaus]
vielleicht wussten nicht wer das ist ja
sie war auch ganz irritiert warum ruft
keiner merkel muss weg ansonsten hatte
sie sich allerdings eine relativ große
woche ausgesucht für ihren besuch in
washington
denn trump ist gerade selbst für seine
verhältnisse echt durch den wind gestern
ruft er das frühstücksfernsehen von
seinem hof seiner fox news an und hört
gar nicht mehr auf zu lagern
für mich war die york durch albert link
kollegin zu tun
ja
hörte mich ja auch deswegen haben wir
damals unsere oppenheim nur noch ein
spielzeug telefon hingestellt sprechen
es offen aus das deutsch amerikanische
verhältnis ist so schlecht wie nie wie
lange nicht
trump hat uns deutsche ist ja so trump
hat uns deutsche wörtlich als sogenannte
alliierte bezeichnet er hat uns böse
genannt böse deutsche das klingt doch
schon falsch wir geben zu wenig geld für
rüstung aus sagte unser
handelsüberschuss sei asozial was stimmt
aber egal
der neue liebling der amis das wissen
sie ist jetzt ein franzose eindeutig
emanuel makro wurde diese woche in
washington man muss das so sagen
geradezu hofiert hier sehr verstörende
bilder irgendwo zwischen liebe und
pflegestufe 3
zwischen frage wieso weiß trump was
schuppen sind braucht man dafür nicht
echte haare
trump und makro trump und marco das ist
wirklich die prominenz des jahres eine
neue dimension der zärtlichkeit wenn sie
mich fragen natürlich der franzose das
müssen wir lassen der franzose hat zwar
auch kritik geübt an den usa vor allem
bei seiner kongress rede aber
hauptsächlich weil er sich drei tage
lang behandeln lassen der kontrast
zwischen den beiden staatsbesuchen war
wirklich brutal auf diese macros hat
melania die first lady sich wochenlang
vorbereitet hier von der offiziellen
seite des weißen hauses
alte ein theater es waren doch nur
franzosen meine güte hier das waren die
vorbereitungen für den merkel besuch
[Musik]
begeisterung im studio aber ich bin
traurig traurig man muss das akzeptieren
makro ist jetzt der neue star europas
der strippenzieher der visionär der mann
mit den ideen während wir mit merkel
geistig schon in frührente sind ist ja
so frank und macao die haben als ja wir
haben diese chemie und ich fand es ja
fast schon niedlich wie stolz der
präsident auf seinen ersten richtigen
staatsgast war
[Musik]
sein erster
erster richtiger freund muss ein toller
moment sein so aber zurück zu uns was
ist jetzt die bilanz von merkels zweiter
besuch bei trump mit ihren washing
natürlich wie immer auch vertreter
unserer wirtschaft würde schneider zum
beispiel ist pressesprecherin des
verbands der deutschen
automobilindustrie
frau schneider was mich interessieren
würde durften sie dann mit in der
kanzlermaschine fliegen acht erwachsene
frau merkel darf mit uns in ihrer
maschine fliegen würde er gerne
vergessen die frau ist in erster linie
handlungsreisende bei uns im außendienst
nicht mit einem ganz simplen auftrag
besorgt uns eine schriftliche garantie
von trump wo drinsteht keine höheren
zölle auf deutsche autos nie und sie
hartz verborgt vor verbockt man am ende
ist sie halt doch ein ossi bringen ist
kapitalismus bei ja was hätten sie denn
machen sollen
gerhard schröder das waren autokanzler
den contest in nachts um drei anrufen
der farbe software
der hat uns geholfen
ja was hat der merkel machen sollen
hemmungslos schleimen natürlich wie der
makro der hat eine schleimspur gelegt
von hier bis paris
das war ja schon hart an der grenze zur
prostitution wird jetzt sogar verfilmt
[Musik]
[Applaus]
apo macro so geht's staatsoberhaupt
augen zu und an frankreich denken
dagegen an unsere bundesrat führte
merkel mein gott mein gott dabei ist der
tramper wirklich pflegeleicht da musst
du einfach immer wieder sagen du bist
der geilste du hast es voll drauf du
hast die haare schön
sie lacht ja nicht mal über seine
schlechten witze wie sie noch bei ihrem
letzten besuch der macht diesen mörder
geht und sie was das abhören durch die
letzte regierung betrifft na ja
vielleicht haben wir da wenigstens eine
gemeinsamkeit
spinnt die lernt man doch schon als
kleines mädchen wenn ein mann versucht
witzig zu sein dann lacht man gefälligst
[Gelächter]
sagt ihnen was wenn unsere autoexporte
wegen der einbrechen
ich dreh durch durchmacht zur noten
sparen zum kanzler ist mir wirklich es
ist mir scheißegal ja sowas so machen
wie die australier so viele us waffen
kaufen dass der trapp uns wieder lieb
hat exakt man kaufen halt was weiß ich
den flugzeugträger melania und legen des
teilens steinhuder meer song what the
mack hat dem trump in paris eine fette
militärparade spendiert genau das
brauchen wir auch wenn der präsident
demnächst nach berlin kommt die
bundeswehr übt das gerade schon mit
allen noch funktionierenden
waffengattungen
wir sind so was von dem aus man muss
jetzt was passieren die merkel wo ist
die merkel angela ja wo ist denn da ist
die werke vielleicht guckt der tram
gerade aus dem fenster muss tanz gibt
mir ein t-shirt mir ein mph scheiße mann
die frau hatten rhythmusgefühl wien sagt
gulas das tut mir leid birte schneider
meiner mutter
[Applaus]